[Musique]
bonjour jean claude duverger web bonjour
êtes chef de groupe d'ensembles pour une
martinique nouvelle
j'aimerais du verger jeudi et vendredi
jour de plénière à l'assemblée de
martinique pourquoi avons nous cette
impression que cette plénière plus
particulièrement risquent d'être animés
chaude vous ressentez ça également oui
juste avec mes émissions c'est ça au
kadima télé aux côtés de dimaga dit tout
beau tout ça pique à goutte et nous a
fait mal aux mains des biches
non il y as mais ça ce concept là même
c'est une réalité c'est de le
prolongement de la souffrance déjà de
manière générale avait dit que tous les
joies d'un pays au katanga crier que
yusuf est donc aux preneurs qu'on a
l'impression que maintenant il y a déjà
acquis qui ont défendu cet immobilisme
et qui aujourd'hui parce que faute mais
sortie à ça mais dans la réalité je vous
le disais je ne me réjouis de rien du
tout ça macquarie tienne c'est que si in
hymne y compris chez chuo même si terry
connaître que pays à bloquer que n'ont
pas calé mcgeechan que johan poth
logement toutes les conférences de
presse qu que nous avons tenu une
explication nous intervention pour dire
il faut faire quelque chose le pays est
en souffrance je crois du verger ou qu'a
fait beaucoup quand je dis ça parce que
ça soutient donne des succès électoral
dernier dany potas ne me permet pas mapa
mapaq au sabre et lolo aller et pour
google books a allégué
ça veut dire que pour personne peut
m'empêcher moins marquée que dépit 2015
au lieu dit qu un peuple écrasé nous
toute élection allait aux pnpp sonhos
epoté et même si nîmes ou non parmi eux
c'est des cas les monnaies l'uqam et
ouais ça veut dire que dans la réalité
c'est cela mais ça qui est important
c'est qu'ils paient vraiment bloqué
parce que personne pas les 10 ha et
jeudi apprécié puisque lui ont rapporté
nos que yan monplaisir que c'est quand
même vice président l'assemblée
nationale chef de file de la droite
composantes de l'assemblée de bois
payant chance ne connaître que payable
au tce que équipe tu as la paix de la
confiance des matinées et que lui-même
qu'à tirer
quant au clip ou dis que tu as dit
trouver la parole au cas où kim en
équipant les jo dia mais ouzou train de
créer notre ado brecht à la nouba n'a le
bac ça veut dire que ça nous savent et
ça s'il dit sa première main et barredo
nîmes
ça veut dire qu'ils ont fait l'objet
depuis jeudi ipad iai est parce qu une
série de coups de pétard mouillé ou bien
un grand mouvement petit coup de bateaux
etc
mais dans la réalité c'est pas important
que est ce que yann à d'un des hauts
débits épis et l'exécutif et il ya des
animaux ça qui est important c'est que
ini moon de plus en plus car iconiques
que mme harel a pas qu'à des îles
compris parmi eux c'est ça qui casse un
vrai bar tabac moustapha ka alé la
martinique boubou de la martinique à
l'arrêt et il n'y a un bookmaker dirige
et qui part a coûté personnes mais s'ils
échouent et c'est pas lisse elle j ai
joué ces groupes là parce que si on
imagine en bas mais audi mais ce qu on
aimerait faute ils savent aussi que
monsieur couillonner tout môme que
l'idée mené un bras me suis aussi donc
dans la réalité si bateau avait coulé
c'est toute l'équipe et cela aussi qui
pourrit m'étais coiffure question pour
dix gars ça me fait peur qu'elle soit
considérée ou jean claude duverger que
alfred marie-jeanne n'y en eut pas
qu'après bien et pino gros clou en bacs
le pays
et puis en boule catherine louis
bouderait que kita focalisez beaucoup de
ressenti négatif non seulement au parc à
travers le parc naturel régional de
martinique parce que c'est la ligne en
gros contrat en prison mais à d'autres
secteurs que iliad un ace et cette
maladie les marins pêcheurs les sportifs
ou non mais bout très seiichi regroupe
la tout ça bout de l'un fait c'est ça
groupe l'aller ça veut dire que si paix
sont pas là des naucellois d'enjeu
politique locale disposera d'un jeu
politique inite boukris qui a d'un
d'aller personnalisé problème que si mou
de la première main mais s'ils savent si
bien qu'au musée messieurs pas bon ça
veut dire comme il se cacher chez d
autres pas tous les malades à des
maladies grâce à sa musique à aller
embêter un bon café avait lieu au parc
naturel des services comme guy macary
makadji boukar radio ça mais c'est
peut-être ça aussi au fait derrière h
quitter la ctm là aussi c'est peut-être
c'est mon l'acteur a fait de comité
martiniquais du tourisme et le comité
martiniquais du tourisme avait dit que
président est là même quota de manière
moins 4 av et puis moi je dit il et il
avait dit que c'est un monde s'est passé
par côté letchimy dépassé et on va
bosser dur comme on n'a pas beau père a
fait la bei doit considérer en chasse
aux sorcières il est plus l'arrivée
d'alfred marie jeanne philippe vous ça
veut dire comme l'impression que n'y a
d'ailleurs quitté comprennent que les
délits bella même si orthez ionale
c'était pour travailler pme n'ont ni en
campanie moon qui accompagne essaka
étonné - s'il ya mon plaisir dit qu'à
pâti de matras mokady part at il dit
tout simplement que les pas contents et
qu' il pas l'étouffer puisse encore été
dit ça il a été obligé fait un bruit
sifaoui boudissa ça voudrait dire qu'on
était a dit plusieurs fois et puis après
un goûter
ça veut dire que personne n'a écouté
personne et comme une ipp lisier groupe
à gaza ce que nie à l'oci qui café mais
boue chutes pour qui localiseraient
effet ben oui c'est parce que savent que
personne batelli diaye mais aussi un
jour monde osé dire bataille c'est que
vraiment mandat ni courage lit alors que
l'ohada finalement craquelots dit yan
monplaisir mapaq a applaudi and mon
plaisir parce que kaka cemac a applaudi
le fait que tout moungali premiers pays
à bloquer y compris là aussi minimum et
bio c'est ça qui est beau tout un peuple
un peuple à baby gym en salle 6 tab à 1
un choc violent ou pas ça mon visage
et bien tout compte fait c'est mais
c'était à fait conférence de presse émis
cet été où viennent ces miss et elle a
dit que bell a bloqué le kawa est bloqué
mais ne comprennent pas ni personne qui
tp dit hayek en fait ni au lait mais
parce que si je ne prends la parole
qu'après la parole officielle du cac
prend la parole lors de groupes mois
décembre lors qu'elle fait de l'année
que grâce emblée bois payant chance au
pouvoir nous pourquoi mi parcours
mais hook à penser que a nié pas
qu'avant ça dans mon pays talent ça veut
dire qu'on puisse y mettre à penser que
a est passé mais même quand même penser
que c'est par faiblesse ou bien par ses
seins volonté que aeb avancées proposées
franchement même si ou pas d'accord
politique montagne en voulant qu'ils
maniaient un élu paix des dialogues
kenya volonté manifeste de blues un pays
de trie pays a annoncé sa volonté
manifeste ça veut dire que c'est mal aux
mains des moments et chiffons fait mais
dans la réalité 6,6 me dit ça mocap
analyse mais mais mais ça veut dire quoi
simon fait sahnouni a fait la demande à
la nouvelle fois un beau bébé et
letchimy prouver mais s'ils m'ont dit
que nous paie pas failli et un cadre
d'alep il m'a fait me roddick subit
comme les 6es d'un article 73 3 vendredi
nous jean claude duverger que seulement
guti taino bacri la 7e puis pas
permettre de ferraille et donc équipe là
qu'il a caen nous dit quoi puisque
nouvelle faille épisodes et en paca fine
ajouté aapl.o baghai mes équipes latina
comité dit c'est pas unitaire qui était
bon préfet esprit pas failli et pour
passer sur des outils ababou quad cab
aeby mais là c'était m
quand nous fait ici même la région du
cap cabaye là le conseil général
télétravail maillot ou penser à
l'assemblée unique d âme et et colis des
bayous france m'agrippe aux côtés d'une
assemblée unique mais gijoe dit mme
panis l'idée que la cpmc l'assemblée
unique mais est mis en cause sur la
région amos au conseil général
brad des fon mme may soul un ballet
abbas et même au point de vue social
tenir présidente yvette 19 20 la rosée
général pourquoi démissionner tibesar qu
on ne s'attaque à passer pourquoi ici
effet épi soins les minimes paradis
fanni so éliminé et pour l'autriche et
cohade un stratégie précis montrabe amis
c'est ça et puis c'est pas ou lycées -
qui a dirigé mesut miens volonté ou de
l'album working expérience wadi parotide
a commenté la plice comédienne au
périple chez nous peut harmoniser et
c'est sallie pas fait
merci beaucoup jean claude duverger
encore appelée crosser
grand mapipi ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle épine ogawa qui aime
bien ce cas ni au sein de la cei de
martinique pipelinières la quitte a fait
jeudi et puis demain merci bonne journée
[Musique]